Ein astronaut oder eine astronautin erkrankt im weltraum im gegensatz. Zur erde kann dass dort sehr schnell lebensgefährlich werden, ein
Krankenhaus gibt es nicht und die möglichkeiten zur behandlung sind eingeschränkt aber vor allem die
Auch der diagnose doch jetzt ist es einem
Forschungsteam der nasa gelungen bakterien direkt mit einem test an bord
zu identifizieren das ist wirklich eine sensation
Und ein riesenfortschritt, er durch dieses spannende thema whatsapp gewünschte bekommen wir jetzt alle wichtigen facts dazu
Und vor allem wie der hurrikan habe das unterfangen fast. Gestoppt hätte. Und was das für das außerirdische
Leben und dessen entdeckung bedeutet jetzt den. Blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Einen themenvorschlag über whatsapp bzw die anderen messenger vielen dank. Dafür wie er da dabei sein könnt und themen vorschlagen
Und vor allem die unzuverlässige abo box von youtube. Überlisten könnte das erfahrt. Ihr am ende des videos
Es könnten milliarden ja sogar billionen von. Mikroben sein die sich an bord der iss der internationalen raumstation
Tummeln und wie hier auf der erde können die bakterien uns menschen krank machen doch im all ist eine erkrankung
natürlich noch einmal eine verschärfte situation
Denn, hier kann medizinische hilfe anders als auf der erde nicht in vollem umfang gewährleistet werden deswegen dürften forschung zu weltweit schon länger daran
Tests, zu entwickeln mit denen, sich proben direkt vor ort analysieren lassen
krankheiten könnten besser, und vor allem schneller
Diagnostiziert werden und zudem könnte so auch einfach erforscht werden wie die mikroben mit der schwerelosigkeit
Im all zu recht kommt bislang mussten die proben tatsächlich zur erde in entsprechende labore
Gebracht werden eine aufwendige und kostenintensive und vor allen dingen langwierige sache ja und stellt euch mal vor setzt
Außerirdische lebewesen können so direkt vor ort analysiert werden
Ein, forschungsteam der nasa ist es jetzt tatsächlich gelungen solch eine möglichkeit, zu entwickeln herausgekommen ist ein
Zweistufiger prozess mit dem namen jeans in space free der mittlerweile auch bereits in der praxis umgesetzt werden. Konnte
Und zwar auf der uss dazu sammelten die beteiligten forscherinnen. Und forscher zunächst von verschiedenen oberflächen der raumstation proben
und gaben sie in petrischalen durch den zusatz an der nährlösung
Konnten sie die mikroben vermehren in einem weiteren schritt isolierte das forschungsteam, deren erbsubstanz
mit hilfe der sogenannten polymerasekettenreaktion
Die kennt ihr vielleicht. Noch aus dem chemieunterricht
vervielfältigten sie die dna der zweite schritt des prozesses wurde von peggy weit durchgeführt vielleicht habt
Ihr ihren namen schon, mal gehört sie ist rekord astronautin
Und tatsächlich die frau weltweit die die längste zeit im weltraum verbracht hat die biochemikerin
Schaute sich das erbgut also genauer an und erstellte eine sogenannte sequenz analyse dadurch lassen, sich charakteristische
abschnitte der dna also dass erbgutes identifizieren
Und so feststellen, um welchen organismus es sich handelt als wichtigstes instrument dient. Ihr dabei, ein
Mini e on ein tragbarer sequenziert automat gerade mal. So groß wie ein handy
Zitat, sofort haben wir gesehen dass. Ein mikroorganismus
Auftaucht und dann noch, ein zweiter. Und so weiter sagt eine der beteiligten forscherinnen. Sarah wallace dieser ganze prozess fand tatsächlich
Komplett an bord der uss. Also im weltraum stadt absolute premiere. Und sensationen. Und zwar nicht
Einfach weil die astronautin sally ride bei dem komplizierten verfahren vom boden aus geführt werden musste doch es sollte spannend bleiben, denn
Unvorhersehbare geschehnisse bedrohten den, erfolg des projektes allerdings kurioserweise nicht im all sondern auf der erde konkret ging es
Um den hurrikan herr w der hochwasser. Und gefährliche straßenverhältnisse mit sich brachte
So war das team das pegi weit im all unterstützte gezwungen eine zeitlang auf die persönlichen handys zurückzugreifen
Und so hilfestellung an die iss zu übermitteln doch die analysen liefen fehlerfrei
Und konnten später in laboren auf der erde sogar. Mehrfach bestätigt werden jetzt können damit in zukunft in raumschiffen aber auch
außerirdische organismen untersucht und
identifiziert werden ein riesenfortschritt für die wissenschaft wenn
ihr kein video zur entdeckung von außerirdischen deren entdeckung vermutet die nasa schon bald
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube wisst
ihr ja diese immer ziemlich lückenhaft über den messenger erfahrt
Ihr von mir land vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich
Ein kleines goodie für euch am besten. Auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs, um, social and media abonnieren da erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken und natürlich nicht achtung
Genau, die glocke vergessen wie geht s weiter dafür auf draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran